speaking of people who have not earned
any respect in the office that they hold
here's this from fox news that says more
than 60 concerned parents students and
residents spoke at the loudoun county
school board meeting
tuesday evening with many demanding the
resignation of loudoun county
superintendent scott ziegler in the wake
of allegations that the school district
covered up two alleged sexual assaults
parents attended the school board
meeting with signs urging ziegler to
resign
uh parents pointed to two alleged sexual
assaults the first of which the victim's
father claims took place on may 28th
this is from the daily wire report which
we which we talked about yesterday we
talked about on the backstage show as
well
the father says his ninth grade daughter
was assaulted in the bathroom by a boy
wearing a skirt
elizabeth lancaster the attorney for the
father of the alleged victim said the
boy was charged with two counts of
forcible sodomy one count of anal sodomy
and one count of forcible fellatio
the sheriff's office
says
told fox news we can confirm a may 28
2021 case that involved a thorough
two-month-long investigation that was
conducted to determine the facts of the
case prior to the arrest this case is
still pending court proceedings the
loudoun county sheriff's office is not
able to provide any documents that
pertain to a pending case
at a june 22nd board meeting ziegler
declared quote that the predator
transgender student or person simply
does not exist
and that to his knowledge quote we don't
have any record of assaults occurring in
our restrooms
so that's what he said on june 22nd he
said there's no record of any assaults
occurring in in restrooms meanwhile on
may 28th there was this alleged assault
that was already making its way through
the legal system that police had been
made aware of
are we supposed to believe that ziegler
the superintendent i mean
a a girl was allegedly
violently brutally raped
in a bathroom during school hours
and we're supposed to believe that
ziegler
didn't know about it
well that's impossible to believe
it's just it's impossible to believe
so we can look at this i don't think we
have to say it's an alleged cover-up by
the school board it's a cover-up
this horrible thing happened allegedly
and you denied that it happened at all
that's what cover-up is
and we could say that even without all
the other details that we get from the
father about how when he went to the
school after this happened when they
called him to come in
and and they told him they want to keep
it in-house
even without that
you've got
clear indication proof of a cover-up
when the superintendent denies that it
happened
when he had to know about it
so school board meeting was yesterday
and uh let's play this is from fox with
some of the clips here of the parents
trying to hold the school board
accountable for this um for this
cover-up let's listen
the
to a vote 80-40
consideration for the safety of all
students simply to satisfy a political
agenda your moral compasses are busted
you dr ziegler and our school board
every one of you
are complicit in these crimes against
our children because you did nothing
about it
what is worse than a child being raped
at school the cover-up by those who are
entrusted with the safety and well-being
of children warned you about policies
that you were putting into place that
would be a danger to our students
and we've seen that happen when is
enough is enough
when are we going to change the policies
to keep our children safe
this is not china this is the united
states of america and we will not be
silenced you are liable for these
injustices remove the superintendent
immediately and then resign for your
negligence and duplicity
the fact that i have to be here to fight
for my rights to not have more radical
agendas shut down from in school is not
only concerning it's upsetting
uh the the the last one there is a court
it's hard to hear
uh exactly what's being said
and that's all by design i mean that's
why they have to wear the masks
the the masks function in in this case
as literal muzzles that's why you have
to that's why they've required them to
put them on
i mean there's there's no other audience
in the room
they're standing there given 60 seconds
to address the school board
with nobody within 15 feet of them
they can't take the mask off
they can't take it off for 60 seconds so
that they can speak and be understood
no they can't take it off because they
want the words to be muffled
these despicable gutless scumbag cowards
will do everything they possibly can
to avoid any kind of accountability
whatsoever
uh but these loudoun county parents
they they continue to put on
a clinic
for that other parents across the
country should should really follow
there's a there's a model here that's
being presented
and i obviously saw it for myself
when i became a resident of loudoun
county when i was there
that they've got it organized they know
exactly what they're doing
and now because they're only given 60
seconds
to speak out about the cover-up of a
violent rape of a girl in a bathroom
during school hours
they're only given 60 seconds to talk
about what it means is that um
you know
then you you just need you need 30 40
parents in a row hitting on this same
time because they only get 60 seconds
and if you also if you all stay on this
on the same topic and you stay on
message then
cumulatively you've you've spoken about
it for 40 minutes 50 minutes
and that's exactly what they're doing i
hope they continue to do it
every single school board meeting
every person that goes up there
should be specifically calling for scott
ziegler
if i forgive scottish his first name
anyway of for yeah scott ziegler
to step down because of this issue until
he does
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated